was ist jetzt mittellos ihnen mass
krempelt alles um aber auch wirklich
alles was kann man eigentlich nicht wenn
die nasa mit der russischen
weltraumagentur roskosmos gerade einmal
eine raumstation in die mondumlaufbahn
bringen will um verfahren für zukünftige
marsmissionen zu testen startet space
sechs mal eben direkt zum mars 2022 soll
die erste space extrakte zum mars
aufbrechen 2024 dann die erste bemannte
mission wow jetzt alle details zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen
wir hatten ja schon in einem der letzten
videos über nachrichten vom
internationalen astronauten kongress in
adelaide berichtet igor komarow chef der
russischen raumfahrtbehörde roskosmos
hat über die kooperation bei der mond
raumstation deep space gateway berichtet
auf ihr und mit ihr sollen techniken für
die landung auf dem mars erprobt werden
ihnen maske hatte ja schon vor einiger
zeit seine maß pläne verkündet der
hammer erwin mit 1000 raketen den mars
besiedeln und jetzt hat er seine pläne
konkretisiert und es wird noch
spektakulärer
wobei er seine pläne an einem punkt
reduziert hat er will kleinere raketen
einsetzen damit es preiswerter und
finanzierbar wird statt zwölf metern
durchmesser sollen sie jetzt wirklich
einen durchmesser von neun metern
aufweisen länge 48 meter ohne den
booster der die rakete antrag das
volumen ist mit 825 kubikmetern größer
als das eines airbus a380
die raketen sind damit größer als alles
was die menschen bisher ins all
geschossen haben 106 meter ist die
gesamthöhe mit den antriebs stufen
deshalb haben sie auch einen ganz
speziellen namen big fucking rocket kurz
bfr
er will die rakete in zwei jahren
entwickeln starb soll in der ersten
jahreshälfte 2018 sein und bereits 2022
sollen die ersten zwei bfs bereits
ungarn zum mars fliegen
diese ersten missionen sollen dort nach
wasser und rohstoffen und gefahren für
menschen suchen überhaupt zum mars zu
gelangen fliegt die bfr erstmal in eine
erdumlaufbahn und trifft dort auf
treibstofftanks die vorher in den
erdorbit geschossen worden sind sie sind
gefüllt mit methan und sauerstoff und
treiben die raketen auf dem flug zum
mars an die ersten menschen die dann
2024 zum mars fliegen sollen produzieren
dort beim treibstoff für den
flug zur erde vier bfr sollen dann zum
mars fliegen zwei wand und zwei
unbemannt mit diesen flügen soll dann
die mars kolonie aufgebaut werden die
bfs sollen dabei wieder verwendbar sein
um die kosten niedrig zu halten mit
jedem flug plant machst dann 100
menschen plus fracht in 40 kabinen zum
mars zu fliegen
die bsr sind zusätzlich mit großen
gemeinschafts bereichen frachträumen und
so weiter ausgestattet alles was man
braucht momentum auch hier auf der erde
von a nach b zu gelangen und maske wäre
nicht maske länder mit dem bfs nicht
auch das reisen nicht auf der erde
revolutionieren wollte er will die
raketen einsetzen um das reisen auf
unserem heimatplaneten dramatisch zu
verkürzen dubai new york 29 minuten los
angeles toronto 24 minuten new york
shanghai 39 minuten und so weiter und so
fort geschwindigkeit 27.000 kilometer
pro stunde
laut macht kann er mit dem bfs jeden ort
der erde in unter einer stunde erreichen
das klingt jetzt alles eigentlich
vollkommen unrealistisch aber maskat ja
schon einiges erreicht das springt aber
jetzt wirklich den rahmen wahnsinn wenn
es neues dazu gibt halte ich euch
natürlich hier bei pixum auf dem
laufenden wenn ihr kein video verpassen
wollt dann drückt man hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den genau auf
die glocke denn nur dann werdet ihr auch
wirklich über neue videos informiert
hier geht es weiter mit 1000 raketen für
maß mit noch mehr infos zu mass
mars-mission da besteht gipfel ich würde
ich mal sagen also unbedingt hier
draufklicken und angucken und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran